[Music]
behavioral addiction is a lot like
substance addiction in a lot of ways but
it's much newer so substance addiction
obviously involves the ingestion of the
substance and in the short term that
feels good and in the long term it it
harms your well-being in some respects
it can be physiological it can be
psychological that can harm your social
life it can cause you to spend too much
money it can have a lot of negative
effects on your life behavioral
addiction is similar the big difference
though is that a real addiction does not
involve the ingestion of the substance
and it's much newer it's a much more
recent phenomenon so substance addiction
has been around for a very long time by
some accounts for many thousands of
years but their word behaviors around
that were compelling enough to rise to
the level of addiction until quite
recently and the reason is that for them
to be addictive basically what has to
happen is that there's a behavior that
you enjoy doing in the short term that
you do compulsively so you keep
returning to it over and over again but
that in the long term harms your
well-being and it can again harm your
well-being in lots of different respects
social financial physical psychological
and I think the reason why we've got
these new forms of addiction there are
two main reasons the first one is that
technology is much more sophisticated
and advanced than it was even 20 years
ago you're able to deliver the kinds of
rewards that you need for a system to be
addictive so basically what people are
looking for is unpredictability and
rapid feedback of either rewards or if
it's negatives then negative experiences
and you actually need that mix of
positive and negative feedback just as
for example when you post something
online sometimes you're going to get a
lot of hits sometimes you aren't and
it's that unpredictability that we find
so compelling you need to be able to
deliver those rewards really rapidly and
for that you need the internet with the
right kind of bandwidth to be able to
deliver those rewards the other thing
that I think has happened is that
companies are much savvy about this
they're employing behavioral experts to
tell them how to design their media how
to design the vehicles that deliver
those media smart phones iPads
smartwatches things like that and for
that reason I think they are delivering
products to us that are
harder for us to resist they've got
enough features built-in that we find to
be pretty hard to resist that we end up
developing addictions to them and by
some counts that applies to about half
of the population of the developed world
it turns out that it's not the addiction
to the device itself it's that the
device is just an incredibly effective
way of delivering addictive content so
when you're addicted to a screen it's
not that the screen itself is something
that you can't get enough of it's what
it's providing I think one of the
reasons why we're so addicted to screens
or to the content they provide is that
they go with us wherever we go and
that's relatively new so if you play
video games in the 80s or 90s or even
the early 2000s they didn't really go
wherever you went as much as they do now
especially those games that were tied to
the Internet
those were tied to your PC you play
where you were and you didn't really
leave with them as much you had some
portable devices but those were much
more primitive today with iPhones you
can connect to other people on the go
you always have access to games you
always have access to email you always
have access to the Internet and you
always have access to social media and
so they are great vehicles for providing
the hits that you need when you need
them and basically we tend to develop
addictions when we have a psychological
need and we get those when whenever
we're bored whenever we're feeling a
little bit lonely whenever we're not
really sure what to do with ourselves
next whenever we don't feel particularly
efficacious like we're having an effect
on the world that we'd like to be having
those are the moments when you're
looking for what some people call the
adult pacifier and smartphones tend to
be a great adult pacifier because at
those moments you turn on your screen
you swipe and you feel relaxed again
that's that's how people describe the
experience so they tend to be an
excellent devices for delivering these
small hits that we look for and social
media is a great example so social media
obviously now travels with us it used to
be confined to home computers to a large
extent that's no longer the case and
people spend about three hours a day on
average using their smartphones which is
pretty staggering that's a huge chunk of
the day of the waking hours that we
spend when we're not at work and what
that means is they're spending a lot of
that time returning over and over again
to check Twitter Instagram Facebook
snapchat and so on and
checking for a number of things one
thing is that that these media are
bottomless which means that you're
constantly checking for new information
there's always something new to be kept
up on the other thing is if you happen
to be a poster of content you're very
curious about getting rapid feedback as
to whether people approve of that or
they're not particularly interested in
it so a lot of the time what we do is we
return over and over again compulsively
to see whether we're getting the
positive feedback that we seek when we
post content there's a lot of what we're
doing when we post content is basically
testing the social waters getting a
sense of whether people see the world
the same way we do which is very
important to us as humans and also
getting a sense of whether they approve
of us and social approval is really
important but we're even willing to risk
negative feedback because the worst
thing that can happen to a human is to
be ignored it's actually far worse to be
ostracized or ignored than it is to get
negative feedback so when you put all of
that together the idea now that we have
access to theoretically billions of
people in the world at all times
wherever we are
makes smartphones addictive we can
always get that feedback that we desire
[Music]